my house got robbed before and I saw
them and I went to go get my gun and
they all hopped the fence and stuff like
that when the cops came I was just
trying to like really understand what
what the law would be they said that if
like I got corn because it was four
Dudes if I got cornered by all four and
I felt like my life was in danger I
could probably shoot and get away with
it but the problem is if the minute I
pulled out a gun and all four of them
get scared and turn their backs on me if
I shoot then I'm in deep deep [ __ ] I
should Rob people like this yeah like
that's that's a tough one because like
you're already in danger with four
random people in your house let's say
some dude's on top of you right you guys
are like a rock and somehow if I stab
them here that's cool and then if I'm on
top of him like this I come like this
I don't know the Whole Foods like
imagine two dudes but they're both very
versed in the loss
illegal illegal we need a referee and
all looks like [ __ ] robbing with the
Stars and [ __ ]